live stream but there's some other stuff
we're going to show off
first
yeah this is the judging panel
introduce yourself
uh hi i'm vivek
i work in the research team
i'm harold i also worked in the research
um i'm chris yeah work on production and
comms so here we are
we're in the research office today and
there's some pretty exciting stuff going
on in research
yeah we can also start with uh
yeah you're working on the bank roads oh
uh yeah i'm working on the uh
bank roads problems uh
the problem is uh
when you're in a turn
um
it's usually the road is usually has a
bank right so this is you might have
studied in uh physics problems where you
know uh
the vehicle should not slip off the road
so there is a bank
uh because of this the amount of
steering you need to give to achieve the
same sort of degree of turn
is different uh if it was a straight
straight road versus if it was you know
a bank turret
um
so
the result that we that we see in open
pilot is uh if you're on a bank road and
you're turning you tend to typically
over cut which is you you go into the
turn
uh which is not desirable so yeah this
is especially true on uh on lane list if
you guys have been driving laneless
you'll notice that that's a a big
problem with laneless still that'll cut
the turns a little bit too much
um
and yeah i think that's one of the big
things that uh blenus can still be
improved on so hopefully
the next project will bring fruition
soon and that'll that'll be improved
and uh hopefully one of the next
releases
um yeah should we go through some show
some of the exciting stuff we've been
working on here in research as well
uh these are our uh training graphs of
the model that's going to be released in
0x10
um looks good what are the
for for someone who doesn't know like me
what's like the blue and what's the
what's the red line oh so this is uh
this is for everything we train a lot of
outputs so this is the loss for the
entire model and then just individual
outputs and so loss is
um kind of some cost right so you want
to keep that minimal it's basically how
accurate it is in predicting
the ground truth
um
in a variety of situations and i mean in
this case it's mostly just like path and
lane lines like you can see in some of
these issue images here so the closer it
matches the ground truth path and lane
lines the lower this value will become
so you can see here training over time
this model took i think a little over a
day to train
you can see the plot's going down
difference being the
the red ones the validation so that's
what we test on so 10 of your data gets
uh separated into a
test cases and then 90 or train on you
can see those two things being different
here
yeah why do we have that initial spike
over in the big loss
oh this initial spike is uh i mean
that's kind of a quirk of the type of
loss function we use we have uh
um we output multiple plans so there's
multiple hypotheses for the plans oh it
takes longer now
to spike yeah
yeah it changed i changed the weighting
quite a bit on this that was one of the
bugs that we fixed in this relationship
so we down weighted this and it was just
sometimes picking garbage solutions uh
but yeah so basically this is kind of
like a competitive thing that this the
ground truth for this depends on the
model so it kind of changes throughout
you throughout training so this is kind
of not the shape you normally see during
training
um i think we explained that a little
bit better in some of the blog posts the
way these hypothesis uh models work it's
kind of a little bit more complicated
um on the right here we have a new
new thing we're trying out we thought
maybe it'd be nice to explain some of
the things we're changing in the release
so we wrote uh we're always still in the
process of writing it but we thought
we'd write a little blog post explaining
some of the the big changes hopefully
some people that are interested in the
more detailed changes but you know don't
want to read through the commits of open
pilot can i can get something out of
this
yeah yeah it's pretty cool
yeah i don't want to show the oh we can
show our last uh our last innovation
here in research is uh if you guys have
seen some of our blog posts you know we
use a simulator to train in where here's
kind of a similarity where you can move
around left and right forward and back
so now we're moving forward and back the
it's actually taking diff frames from
the video you can see that truck in the
left moving
but with this latest one uh if we now
freeze the frame we can from the same
frame move around left right forward
back and you can see it doesn't really
look that distorted it's a pretty pretty
good simulation so this is some latest
improvements we made that snake's a
color pencil
yeah pencil my is a big part of this
this is uh all this warping is based on
the segment we use the segment outputs
make some assumptions based on the depth
of the road plane and uh and just the
depth of the surrounding and you can see
this beautiful reprojection it's uh
almost looks like gta 5.
yeah i think that's uh
biggest updates from research
it's pretty fast now
yeah it's not bad
uh yeah it's training now it's it's
twice slow in total this is not too bad
well we're getting a new office we're
getting a big data center
yeah
big things happening yeah very exciting
things i think you guys are excited
about this latest release too it's uh
it's been about a month or something
we've gotten quite a few improvements in
it so
yeah if you look at the release notes
you'll just see like you know new driver
monitoring models so that's why we
really wanted to kind of explain a bit
more
like what these things actually mean uh
because you know it's pretty cool
there's some cool little tricks we do
this is like mask on augmentation
and then uh
field of view of comma three is starting
to be used for uh
for the driver monitoring so that's
pretty cool
all right do we wanna wanna go check it
out let's do it
the videos
thank you all for submitting your
awesome videos to the video contest
means a lot uh we love seeing content
love seeing people driving with
open pilot and uh enjoying what we do so
definitely yeah it means a lot sure oh
we got another another thing to check
out
so
i'm looking into training uh
depthnets
so the comet 3 has much better picture
quality than the uh than the comma 2. so
we're hoping we can finally train
unsupervised depth nets and you can look
at these three frames here
and uh
you see how the you know it's like three
in a sequence so using just this picture
you can figure out the depth of all the
objects in the scene
and this was never possible on comma two
data
uh because if when you looked at the
road on a comma two it would just look
kind of blurry
but this is comma three data and if you
look at the road look at that texture we
can capture
that's a lot of texture yeah so using
this texture we can figure out how far
away the road is
uh based on how the texture moves and
this is just a google paper wow look
look at that word texture oh yeah all
right and you know the tooth is so
detailed blurry uh holy crap
other people's skid marks will help us
learn depth that's right
that's cool another another innovation
coming
down the pipe
anything to say about the videos you
like like community content it's
were we good the videos or is this one
of those things where it's like the
academy awards where they know already
who's going to win
we know who's going to win
the academy awards we have the envelope
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
all right let's go let's build the
suspense anyway yeah
yeah nobody don't know who's gonna win
yet
i mean we'll start with honorable
mentions first of all the first category
we're gonna talk about there's two
categories remember first category was a
general review of your common device
comma three and the second category uh
was laneless videos showing off lane
lists i mean they can kind of overlap a
bit but anyway here's uh honorable
mention
wait did this guy uh follow the turning
the speed blue to turning the path blue
he's just riding a fork
but yes
if you're in here
here's your video
pinoy
pinot drives
let's check it out
it's pretty cool
that's me driving hands-free on my
subaru forester
you know how many people use subarus
i wonder which tv the audio is coming
out of it
oh is it coming out of all of them
oh it's coming out the bottom one
um
wow look it's a comma three
oh that that screen looks so nice yeah
right
such a big screen such a deep black
[Music]
but it's pretty a comprehensive video
you know it talks about what is open
pilot uh talks about
their experience with it they even do
some laneless drives in here which is
pretty cool this is on like a laneless
country road oh yeah i love lanes drives
yeah laneless drives are great uh so
that the car is uh you know going on the
right side of the road yeah it's pretty
cool pretty cool
so it just knows like a human
um like a human but yeah this is a great
video and discord i'm gonna post a
playlist that has all the finalists in
there and uh you can all check out the
videos they're also all on our community
uh videos tab on the youtube channel
are you quite impressed by all the late
late submissions
yeah there's quite a few
today quite a few late submissions um
procrastinators are always the best
yes so all right next uh next up is a
let it drive video
we like let it drive let it drive it's
pretty cool
whoa we got a cookie no way
homemade
thoughts on this uh so this is pretty
cool we kind of broadened up the
category of uh comma three review to
just kind of be a general review of open
pilot because some people don't yet have
common threes uh so wait this is i
thought this was a pay-to-win category
well
no pay-to-play pay-to-play
yeah the
the winner does have a comma three to be
fair oh that's good
that's right
so yeah this guy's driven over 10 000
miles with uh open pilot and he he gives
some that's a lot yeah i mean that's a
lot right ten thousand thousand miles to
the open pilot wow what percent of all
the miles yeah that's a pretty good
pretty good quality
i i think i have two yes
um but you know what i like about this
video is he has a whole section about
things he wish he wishes he understood
better before he bought it
things like torque limit like car
specific limitations
it's stuff that we don't communicate
very well yet so i mean i think it's
nice we don't just want to review where
you're just saying all these nice things
about us and nothing critical
yeah i think i especially like the part
where
he did not know that uh the acc was
stuck for a long time after he started
using yeah he was confused why
it wasn't uh i wasn't getting better
yeah why
all the youtube videos that you saw were
so good but then his car was not that
great so it was stuck so yeah
that's good
it's not just about the good stuff we
want a clear honest honest picture
that's right we should know what they're
getting into yeah so i think this video
does a really great job of that you know
providing
some things you should know before you
order but then also
saying how much he loves uh loves using
open pilot
and uh is that a civic type r that what
that was just b-roll but
um
but yeah he also has a shout out for our
awesome support team
oh thanks yeah and the discord yeah
but yeah you know let it drive is great
we love let it drive that's some really
good stuff
so
wait so he uh says talks about whether
he wants to buy a comma three
and he decided he didn't want to buy a
comma three is that what uh
he's saying you should buy a comma three
but he's still chilling with his
commentary he's still waiting he's happy
with his coma too yeah i think he
doesn't yet have the money to get a
comma three that's
so that's great that's another honorable
mention and we'll have a little
announcement about what honorable
mentions may be getting a little bit
later
chris oh we announced that we can
announce it now
every uh honorable mention
gets a hoodie
[Music]
so uh yeah if you're
on the discord feel free to just dm me
uh your size
and but if you're not on discord and
like you're just watching this and your
video came up uh just email support
comma dot ai with your uh your address
and
your size and we'll get a hoodie sent
out to you so it's pretty cool that's
pretty cool 89 value right these kama
hoodies are real good yeah kama hoodies
are super nice so
you get some nice merch
all right we ready for the winner of the
comma three category yeah let's do it
who's doing the drum roll
late submission by the way came out a
few hours ago
oh yes
um
people are better at pronouncing names
than me this one's bi i'll go uh
nice that sounded really good it's just
i guess it could be something completely
different i turned my corolla into a
self-driving car
it's what a brain is logos this is my
car being driven by oh yeah it's a
pretty cyborg brain
uh so yeah this is a great video what i
like about it most especially is that he
kind of explains
what's going on at the beginning like
what is open pilot
which is good i used to do a video uh a
long time ago about what openpilot is
but it's definitely a lot better than
what i like where they show comic-con
clips me too yeah there's a lot of great
comic-con footage out there we really go
through a lot of stuff in detail yeah
we're very proud of it yeah go right
there there's a pretty cool installation
sequence
yeah check it out oh yeah this was super
good this was so good
and it makes it look pretty easy which
is pretty easy it takes some time but i
think anyone can do it yeah i'm just
sticking the mound on correctly with no
angles also a little bit of a
you know just be careful yeah have you
installed hero
uh no not the whole thing that's the
whole thing
i'm waiting until uh it's ready for the
consumer experience
i mean still a lot of amounts to i feel
like a lot half the time you're like you
accidentally touched the windscreen and
i got [ __ ] yeah
yeah so this is great and then you know
it kind of almost qualified both
categories but in some ways it's more
than laneless um but he also shows a lot
of great laneless examples going through
intersections and things like that
and i think uh yeah it's just really
cool how he he shows it's successfully
going through uh intersections in
different ways also you know he's
critical like sometimes it doesn't
always go the right way um but all stuff
we're working to improve so yeah also
another thing that's pretty cool is uh
this person has been uh using for a week
yeah so you can see how his hands are
you know really around the steering
wheel but if you see the other videos of
people uploading the especially the guy
who drove for like 10 000 miles you can
see that his hands are you know quite
comfortably on his lap yeah yeah you
change your behavior a bit over time
don't you yeah
so that's really yeah let's let's check
out some of these yeah like his
intersection tests really cool videos
yeah look at this
it's making a curved intersection uh
look easy look at
that is nice
that's pretty cool oh that's google maps
i didn't even realize that's that great
i almost did that but then i pulled out
my drone for the the videos we did but
that's a great way to to show a top-down
view yeah i really like that
it's a good camera setup i think more
people should show off how they rig
their cameras right i'll probably do
that for us because it's pretty
difficult look at this another nice
laneless road there
so congratulations you win 544 dollars
and 46 cents
also um
this actually i like this bit a lot uh
the rotary the rotary bit yeah that was
you know it was kind of suspenseful
he's in a roundabout it's a pretty big
one yeah it's pretty big he has a image
of the thing yeah there is this
yeah it's a round of applause this looks
like this is this in america
i don't know i've never seen this i
haven't seen that in america either
nice i see you're in the chat so uh wait
this guy has a green path everyone has
different color paths
he's on shane's fork he said
oh i see yeah he's on trainsport yep
um but yeah super uh
hey guys welcome
thanks for all your great submissions
yeah they've been yeah their submissions
are really great over here show my
favorite one
which is that one
no not yet no that's your favorite
maybe we'll play that one in full you
know it's so short yeah but uh that
one's an exciting one i like that one
yeah and this video ends with a nice
time lapse which is always nice
uh so it's a very very good all-around
video yeah this was very complete very
informative yeah so it came out a few
hours ago very
very exciting uh but yeah
544.46 uh you know email support.com ai
if you're not on the discord if you are
just message me virtually chris all
right
so that's the first category comma three
review now let's check out some
honorable mentions in the second
category
which is laneless
so
i thought this was uh
pretty cool is the this guy
has made videos in both
uh for both categories oh yeah and
they're honestly both pretty good so
this is uh specifying his
he's uploaded i think like four videos
in the last week which is great you know
we love having new open pilot youtubers
come to the scene uh i think
education is a big thing and you know
people need to
kind of understand what we're doing and
sometimes we can't just be the only one
saying it so it's very helpful when
people make videos like this yeah i
think it's very good because they know
the things that they didn't understand
before they got into it and the things
that they didn't want to didn't want to
know beforehand right so it's less
sketchy right when you know people use
it and make videos this is the company
making videos yeah right we can try to
be honest but yeah nobody will believe
us anymore yeah for sure yeah even if
we're the most honest company george's
uh
sneak previewing some hackathon projects
wow
common hacks going to be wild
[Laughter]
whoa
we have an announcement too this is a
minor announcement when they're in the
judges okay you want me to come over in
your office when all right sounds good
so well so many announcements today it's
crazy
it's almost just been happening at calm
i know it's it's very busy lately so
yeah this is an honorable mention this
guy does only get one hoodie even though
he
he's done multiple videos
so uh appreciation as well yes we really
do appreciate him we hope you keep
making videos i think they're great
there's literally no subaru content
creators out there so you kind of got a
good niche there
all right another honorable mention
the good old logan legrand
uh we're longtime fans of logan legrand
long time fans he's got some great
content great explanations yeah i'm sure
most of you know logan as well ooh
we're starting off with our honorable
mention there it is i'm going to ship
you a comma hoodie if you are jealous
you can get one on the
shop yep
shop 89. so that's right we'll be uh
sending these to our honorable mentions
thank you so much yeah they're very nice
very high quality
high quality hoodies so yeah what i love
about logan's looking at a new car first
of all i got a highlander
and he told me that he thinks the tuning
lateral and longitudinals better than
his scroll i think the highlander is the
the highest turning rate i've seen on
any open pile of cars i was doing some
metrics on
what's the strongest open pilots ever
turned from the data set and highlander
came up a couple times so it seems like
it's got some of the best lateral uh
control available yeah this is a cool
laneless going through a street like
that really nice
and uh you know logan knows we we always
like when he makes a video he's always
you know very good yeah this is actually
fantastic yeah it's fantastic
he's he's showing it uh oh he said the
highlander's pretty great so far you
just said
so i know you keep getting comma stuff
but now you're getting a hoodie i don't
know if you already have one but you're
getting another one
[Laughter]
yeah so this is basically he's uh
driving straight into this intersection
and then now you can see
yeah
that's nice when pilot made a decision
yeah i think it's great that he's
looking showing the challenges of
lameness as well i mean
lameness is great at a lot of things but
there's also things we're still working
on improving and just inherent
challenges i think it's really cool that
he gives a pretty complete picture and
like the stuff that can still be worked
on yeah so there is one bit that i want
to show
where basically there's a parked car and
laneless you know slightly goes around
the car which is pretty cool to see yeah
that is really cool i wonder where that
is
this video is all full of uh good
good info so maybe somebody here
let's see this is the
intersection one which is also pretty
neat oh it goes right through this
section i guess it was somewhere here
then hmm
i think it was later
oh yeah oh here it is yeah look at that
yeah yeah so you can see that there is a
uh
parked car on the road it looks like a
lead car but then you see lane let's
slightly take
you know it's showing the intros of
something amazing yeah exactly you know
it's a work in progress it's getting
better every release
and i think i've been working on the
end-to-end uh long tuning stuff now
recently and i can see a lot of uh
a lot of potential i'm very optimistic
i've been focusing a lot of bugs
very excited about the next next demo
yeah
yeah one of these weeks maybe we can do
another yeah once we get the next round
of improvements on a branch uh i can see
again
people can see the progress
yeah so congrats logan thanks for your
submission and your continued uh support
we really appreciate that
all right another honorable mention we
can probably play this we can play this
one we'll see if you can hear it uh a
lot of people around the office really
like this one
let's
first of all it's by js
mysterious name
i like js a lot js does a lot of cool
like uh just showing the end to end
stuff even longitudinally but yeah here
we go
whoa look at that
i like this one this is a punchy little
ad yeah pretty cool
yeah yeah
good beats yeah there's good beats we
couldn't pay enough to get an ad like
this
if you ever saw it on tv here's what how
you see it yeah exactly
do you ever make a super bowl ad i want
it to be like this
yes
whoa look it's making a lane change with
no lane lines what
that's impressive dude is it even a lane
change if there are no lines yeah
it's
just something completely different
philosophical question there
whoa is that was that an actual drone
shot
yeah except that's pretty cool yeah this
is great uh a great ad
like a human
we're gonna have to
use that slogan later
so we love that you'll be getting a
hoodie thank you so much for your
continued content it's getting you know
every video you make i see is getting
better so definitely keep it up we
really do appreciate it all right
we've come to the
this point where we got the final winner
coming in final winner yes
and another new content creator someone
who's never made open pilot video before
all right here we go
oh we're always like new community
members we do
all right here i'll try to
uh this one this is less my my yeah my
ethnicity yeah but i'll go with that
[Music]
how
that sounds good oh sci-fi it's sci-fi
oh my god
so sci-fi congrats for winning uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
eddie as the profile picture that's
hilarious that's funny all right let's
just we'll play a brief bit of this
video it's pretty pretty great it's like
a swiss town
we're trying to develop a self-driving
vehicle you know it feels like there's a
really good script in this video like it
feels like
this one really communicated things
super clearly
really communicated what laneless is and
why it exists and why we're approaching
the problem the way we are just yeah
so
yeah it's great he starts have been like
hey how come you can't just have a car
that you know just stays in the middle
of lane lines and doesn't hit anything
but it's harder than that and he he
shows off some great examples here where
we do really good
i think my favorite i mean this is
always a fun example the the country
back road where we do really well even
with no lane lines i wonder how long
this guy's had open pilot he's got his
hands near the wheels yeah i think the
the stickers are popular on the steering
wheel the second person i've seen i've
never seen that do we need to start
doing that that's pretty neat though oh
look there's a truck coming on yeah this
is i you know i was surprised that he
didn't have to take over here just uh
nice it was hugging right enough that
there was no issue
very much though even though there's an
oncoming truck yeah so
pretty sweet and then let's uh let's go
over to my favorite one he shows which
is uh
oh yeah this one's good too
yeah check this out you're not gonna
believe this so he's going through an
intersection first of all and he is
saying like
you know how that's cool in itself that
was a cripped intersection but then look
at these crazy lane lines going on
over here like what is that
if we had any hand coded policy you'd be
so screwed right now because we're
really confused
i'm really impressed with how good the
video footage is in this uh this one
like the the shots of
i guess of the gopro and yeah look
really really good and it's explained
super clearly i think this is a very
well deserved win yeah definitely so you
went sci-fi
544.46 congratulations
so yeah you know we're really
loving all the community videos
definitely keep it up if you like making
videos you know i definitely enjoyed it
when i was making open paddle videos
it's a lot of fun to just drive around
and see what the system can do yeah it's
pretty fascinating yeah it's a very
impressive set of videos yeah
really happy with all the all the
content yeah yeah for sure definitely
definitely yeah good stuff also it helps
around
everyone else who already has open pilot
or who is planning to buy just uh just
good to see
people in the community making videos
and you know
yeah
just nice
it's nice all around so everyone keep it
up i think we might have made some new
open pile youtubers with this contest
which is fantastic keep it up i mean you
know logan has a lot of subscribers now
i got a lot of subscribers just from
doing open pilot videos so if you have
any youtube aspirations this might be a
cool route think of how many people do
fsd videos you know we need more more
open pilot content out there
definitely
do we go see what george's announcement
was yes george you ready for your
announcement
all right
going in
uh
no it's just not on the computer or
anything okay
uh so
um
a bunch of things
it's actually on the board if you guys
are paying attention
uh
how to approach this let's see
um
you have this concept of uh
like
pareto optimality is there anything that
comma
could be doing better
um
and then you know you have you have
optimality with respect to constraints
right
and something i've said around here a
lot of times that should never be a
constraint is uh non-recurring expense
or the amount of money that uh you can
put into things right
a lot of companies now of course
spending money is not good uh spending
money is bad uh hiring people is bad
right people are cost uh this is a lot
of people don't think about business
like this they think about oh people are
growth no no no no sales are growth
right like like i guess for some people
uh you know maybe it's kind of like an
all attention is good attention kind of
theory
uh where it doesn't matter if your
growth is in negatives or positives as
long as the numbers are getting bigger
some people are happy i of course don't
feel that way now
uh so
we are
uh
raising a small amount of money
uh i'm not i don't i don't want to be
sec you know i don't want to be sec here
so like i don't know what i'm allowed to
say what i'm not allowed to say i didn't
i didn't consult with my lawyer before
talking
um
the
it's no it's i'm not gonna okay now i'm
gonna send you this link right now to an
erc20 on on uniswap and you all should a
bit no it's nothing like that it's
nothing like that uh the minimum
investment is a million dollars
uh we have a whole bunch of people
already uh
basically that we've reached out to
uh you know just people we've been in
communication with
um accredited investor obviously
a million dollars minimum
and then um sort of mission aligned
uh if it's the kind of thing where
you think you're gonna get in you're
gonna you're gonna flip or you're gonna
push me at this backing you're not you
get no control
uh but
yeah we raise money in a long time we
are a profitable company we don't have
to but there's two things that we can do
better
than we're doing right now
and the first one is our data center for
research so
the amount of data that we're processing
is going up and the amount of operations
we need to do on that data is going up
so models are taking longer and longer
to train given a fixed size the data
center so we want to make the data
center bigger
uh we're never going to ipo this company
is never going to be owned by bankers
right so once you ipo or you stack your
company is owned by bankers right um and
bankers don't create value bankers are
middlemen so we're not interested in in
anything like that
um you know it's it's uh it's private
equity
uh now
you know uh
i don't know how much should how much am
i allowed to say how much do i say in
private conversations it's on youtube
uh whatever whatever whatever
you know who you are
um
if you're interested in your approach in
the right sort of way
uh there's a possibility
you could be uh included in the round
but again it's really about
people who are aligned with long-term
value creation in the future uh and
hopefully there's enough of them out
there because honestly if there's not
well [ __ ] it we're not raising money uh
but if there are
uh
you can you can uh subtly reach out
uh and i will
justify our valuation talk about our
plans in the future but there's two
basic things uh that money would well
it's not necessary money would help us
uh one is
buying a larger data center why don't
you just put everything in the cloud
yeah great great great you will own
nothing and you will like it
uh no no no we don't like that um the
cloud's very expensive especially for
deep learning so we do we do all our
machine learning stuff on premises we
need a bigger data center uh that also
means we need a bigger office
um we have the the main thing that we've
exhausted at this office is the power so
we're out of power
and we're going to get a new
office with more power and a bigger data
center
and the other thing and we could do this
with debt but
you know i think that
uh if you're the right person you learn
the details of the round you'll see why
we're doing it this way
um is purchasing parts in bulk
so the comma three costs us a lot to
make uh-huh i've you've seen me gripe
about this on many videos um the the
gross margin on the comma three
is is lower than the gross margin on the
comma two uh this is very unfortunate so
for every dollar we we get in from comma
three sales uh we keep less of it more
if it just goes straight out to our
suppliers
but one way that we can mitigate this is
by starting to purchase in bulk uh
starting to purchase stuff in in in real
bulk
uh
so that's another thing that we can we
can do with money
ah
new data center in plano yeah a bunch of
bunch of guys chilling for texas
i don't know i think i think we're going
to stay right here in san diego
uh
i don't think we're moving
but yeah so that's that if you're
interested you know who you are
um
the main thing we're looking for is
people who are aligned with
a long-term value creation for the
future and are not interested in finance
scams
there's a lot of finance scamming going
on today you know
so we we don't we don't do scams
uh we're here to complete our company
mission which is to solve self-driving
cars while delivering fluid trade areas
so i think that's that announcement
i don't think i really have anything
else to
to just to say about that
uh
but yeah what is it oh
four things fourth day copd you know
it's easy to remember right i remember
my talking points right
uh cars
office
parts data center
uh are all places where
we can expand
uh
in such a way that we can accelerate
the uh mission of the company i
accelerate the mission of the company
that's right right so so maybe two years
ago there wasn't really a way maybe a
year ago there wasn't really a way like
a bunch of people reached out to invest
and i was like well
you know really tell me how uh
if we raise more money
uh we can
accomplish the company's mission faster
and i got back a lot of [ __ ] i got
back a whole lot of [ __ ] about well
you could hire more people you could
hire people and pay them more money
god all you're looking for is ways to
you know you know it's like like like
more people people are a liability you
know
you know like we hire we we hire people
we have great people but it's not about
like something like what we're trying to
like oh well we've got to grow i got to
grow my influence in my division so if i
hire more people my division gets bigger
and i have more influence you see none
of that none of that you know comes a
dictatorship right but you get the
benefits of dictatorship
um
yeah uh bulk orders how big you guys
haven't sold that many threes
uh on the order of magnitude of tens of
thousands
um
would you shifting to drones
no
no uh drones
you know
the main problem with people think that
self-driving cars there's some
regulatory barrier for them there's not
the self-driving car barrier is almost
entirely technical
the drone barrier is almost entirely
regulatory it's actually really easy to
make a drone that can fly from point a
to point b because you know there ain't
much to hit in the sky
uh the problem the reason we don't have
drone delivery services has everything
to do with faa regulation
and nothing to do with
the practicalities of building it at
least i hope so i hope you know it's a
much easier problem than self-driving
cars i don't know maybe maybe we've
declined to a point where we can't even
solve that anymore
uh
the dictatorship eventually falls you
know so does the democracy so does every
form of government the trick is to you
know uh sow the sow the seeds when the
when the growing is good
uh does this round of funding mean we'll
have an actual data center now
what do you mean by actual data center
um
i learned the kind of cooling we use in
our data center you know it's like we
don't have air conditioners we just
bought a bunch of fans this is
apparently a real thing it's called free
cooling and facebook does it now too all
these suckers we're spending 40 of their
power bill on air conditioning all right
so no we're gonna still have free
cooling um we are gonna do we're going
to move the filters into the air system
and not to the front of the computer so
we won't have those stupid filters on
the front of the computers anymore
um it's not a data center it's a compute
cluster we're never going to have a real
data center we're always going to have a
compute cluster and that's for legal
reasons
um can i officially call the data center
hell no sorry i should not have said
data center uh s you know data center
slash compute cluster g you know what
i'm saying
uh
so yeah there's that
um
nothing to hit in the sky between aliens
is faking is where these people come
from
uh
why not equity crowdfund god what i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go on on on on wish
stalker whatever those things are
not for me
it's not for me
you know why because like you know
look we're gonna get like probably
really it's gonna be like five people
and i'm gonna talk with these five
people and if they're good reasonable
people they're letting to the round if
they say things that
secretly let me know that they're dirty
bankers well they're not welcome in the
round um but you know the equity with
the crowdfund things
that you know what i mean so you know
you know what i'm saying
um
no i'm not kryptos crypto
while it's not the bankers it's another
class of kind of gross people
i mean no you know what they're better
than the bankers they're better than the
bankers but
uh no we're never doing a a coin
um
so comma can never be acquired uh i mean
i'm
before and after this round i am the
majority shareholder and sole board
member
uh the only way com is getting acquired
is if i believe there's a company out
there actually more capable of achieving
the mission you know you guys heard the
expression yolo you guys know what it
stands for
you know you only live once do you want
to live for bankers i don't live for
bankers
unless you know
build ai and save the world right
uh what is our vision stack going to
replace the car acc is comma a unicorn
uh no no
uh our evaluation is not that high i'm
i'm not a scammer right yeah
again if you're the right type of person
you reach out you get you get all the
details
and uh
[Music]
our evaluation is not a billion yet it
will be it well here's here's an
argument here's a here's a simple
argument for a billion dollar comma
evaluation right
so if we if our final version of the
device is a thousand bucks
and we sell a hundred thousand of them
per year uh that's a hundred million in
revenue with a 10x revenue multiple
that's a billion dollar company right so
pretty pretty straightforward uh
pretty straightforward argument um and
10x revenue multiple is small uh for
reference i think mobile i sold at a 42x
revenue multiple
so you know maybe we're actually maybe
if we're actually selling 100 000
devices a year which is very clearly a
market for um we're looking at
uh
more like a four billion dollar
evaluation that sounds right right
i think that's a good
that's sort of a growth trajectory what
opportunities i kind of hate that word
everybody says the word opportunity
especially when people refer to things
that have like much more normal jaw much
more normal like terms like job and they
say the word opportunity like
i don't know
no uh more cars
uh
so we can you know like for example we
should have something we should have a
chrysler right we don't have a chrysler
right now and people buy the chrysler
and they have bad experience like we
don't want that so we should have like
one car from every brand
um you know the great thing about the
great thing too about all these things
i'm talking about is they're buying
assets right they don't like like i'm
not looking to blow the money on
something stupid
you know what i mean
uh
i don't even know i'm trying to even
think like how these have these people
follow money it's just it's mind-blowing
to me
um
new cars are assets obviously they
depreciate
uh you could hire another deep if you
know another deep uh we'll hire we'd
love to hire
the problem is find another deep you
know
uh
we're always we're always looking
uh you're not rich if you're not rich
you get good private equity you
shouldn't play private equity
uh
the specs are disgusting and somebody
should come in and clean them up
but you know no no no no we gotta
regulate the cryptos but let the stacks
go uh that's what we get
uh
you're in a diva training ah well you
know you know how deep started you
started some import quests
um don't you need advertising to sell a
hundred thousand units
uh how many cars does tesla sell and how
much advertising does tesla do right
it's the same thing um what did tesla do
well tesla did the same thing that we're
gonna do right um you know okay the
common three is is is
something we say a lot around here is
the common three is the most expensive
uh sorry
it probably will be the most expensive
um but it is also the most complex
device uh kamal will ever build the
comma three has a lot of things in it
that are overkill
um which are great
but you know as our stuff gets more
refined it turns out we'll be able to
make do with less
so
look at tesla right tesla launches the
model s great car but eventually in
order to reach mass markets they
launched model 3.
so we have to figure out what our
version of launching the model 3 is but
the trick is the model 3 in a lot of
ways is a better car than the model s
you can see the same thing with oculus
too right you look at the you look at
like the the rift uh i think i think
cv1 was 800 bucks
yeah yeah all right i don't think the cv
cv one crescent bag i forgot exactly
what they called it but uh you see that
you know you can buy like a quest 2 now
for 300 bucks and they're really they're
really i've changed my mind on the quest
too i love the quest though
uh i got a i got a new strap
um that that improved it a lot
i got oculus link cable
but
um
[Music]
feces
uh
making do with less is a super awesome
approach
that's a common right like so so tesla
tesla's cars um
you know the model 3
benefited a lot from years and years of
tesla's experience of building cars and
we're looking for something similar so
to come back to your question do we need
advertising to sell 100k units no we
need a better unit to sell 100k units
the common three is not going to sell
100k units
um the comment three should outsell the
comma two
and
you know so on and so forth
uh i don't stream on twitch anymore
it requires facebook i don't read the
news um
any chance of a blog post going over the
dm model you see a new thing about mask
augmentation that's coming out soon
uh will more more of openpod ever go
from python to being rewritten to c it's
almost all c now what part of it's not c
every every like it's all c
uh fortunately for you tesla's now a
robotics company we were a robotics
company first elon stole all that [ __ ]
from me nah i don't think you stole it
great minds think i like you know but uh
we do use an official epito
change its follow distance based on that
yo yo that's such small-minded thinking
stop thinking like that as a human when
you drive do you think oh i'm in a dense
traffic situation i am going to lower my
following distance to two
right i look like mark zuckerberg uh
maybe that's how he drives um no no no
hate for zuckerberg oculus quest 2 is a
nice product i take back all the hate uh
hints for calibration challenge
computer vision use computer vision
if you've thought about that um
[Music]
when's the next robot c3 is going to be
stuck on the brain yo yo yo yo yo we got
that's what we got this thing for man
um
we're gonna we're gonna stick a comma
three on a pole we're gonna we're gonna
figure out okay we're gonna figure out
look look look um
uh cooks and cleans right how do we make
a commentary cook and clean
uh questions about this are if we're
gonna make it cook and clean
well
how many arms do you need
right this body's probably good but how
many arms you need do you need two or
you use one okay
um
if you have
two arms or one arm how many fingers do
you need on those arms
eta level five all right
four arms i mean maybe you need four
uh is there a chance the nav will take
over the whole screen
yeah we're hiring a designer um we
interviewed someone who's pretty good uh
and they're coming to the hackathon
and yeah eventually we hope for like a
unified the split screen is kind of
what's the simplest thing to imagine but
i think stuff can be done better
um
we're a robotics company oh we're a
robotics company uh
the common i mean
you can think of the car right now as
the common body
all right comma twos connect to a uh uh
we have this car harness which connects
it to the car right but if we want to
attach it to a mop well what does a mop
harness look like we don't we want it to
be generic for like mops and brooms and
knives and forks and spoons and whatever
else you use for cooking i don't know i
don't cook that much pots and pans and
stuff but what is the generic interface
to that it's arms actually wouldn't it
be funny if the comma body could get
into a car and drive driving you know so
i always say like people are thinking
they're building self-driving cars like
you're not building a car you're
building a person
um
any update on open pilot 0.8.10 did you
watch the rest of the video
a little pile will be fully laneless
yeah 0.9
um
oh oh maybe there's a lot of people out
there who don't know what com is and
advertising what comma is
will help advertising's for losers
uh building better products is for
winners
right
eventually if you build something that's
just so good
everyone will hear about it you know
what i mean
like you think they needed to advertise
refrigerators i'm sure they did
especially when there's competition but
if you were the only guy who had a
refrigerator your word get around about
that he's got cold beer
um
a male transporter so i don't even know
what that is tesla advertises on youtube
oh that's too bad they should not
um
don't pay for eyeballs
don't pay eyeballs
all right
it's like the corporate version of
hiring hookers
uh
comma isn't user friendly enough for the
people that are hearing about comma from
an ad exactly so then you get to the
truth of it and the problem is not that
we don't have an ad the problem is the
comma isn't user-friendly enough now
ask yourself this are we more
user-friendly than we were last year are
we more user-friendly than we were the
year before this starts to be a positive
thing to focus on right how do we build
something that is more and more
user-friendly and easier and easier to
use that's an engineering problem right
that's good solve engineering problems
that's how you save the world
um
do you buy algorithms from china
you have to go to the shenzhen markets
here you got any algorithms
yeah
come down here you know it's right next
to the pangolins
um
then you can focus on advertising or you
could never focus on advertising that's
an interesting idea i think of that
uh
yeah we have a well-priced product to
sell the common three represents like
the flagship
comma 3 represents the the the high end
it's nice that's really nice that's not
the iphone sc
you consider an ai on bikes
this time like sometimes i think you
guys are gpg3 you know
have you considered sunscreen for cows
there's a mountain in the middle episode
about that
uh
what's your role in comma that's a
personal question
uh it is well priced i i yeah i think
the commentary is worth it for what you
get
but remember it's also it has to do with
like a market which evolves over time
right so like yeah um
advertising is scam it does not work i
mostly agree with that
uh also you have to remember who you're
enriching with advertising right like
some of it
if we ever even considered it it would
be like
direct with certain you know sort of
content creators who would want to fund
anybody
anybody who's paying for google and
facebook ads it's unforgivable like it's
it's really don't do that don't starve
those companies
um
you know you can figure out how to
directly fund people it's like hey you
make cool content you know yeah yeah
shout me out maybe we'll see
uh
do any electric cars working on pot
not yet
i mean the tesla's the tesla's yeah the
tesla's the tesla's though
uh
i think a bunch of uh you know hybrid
electric vehicles work you know
yeah
ionic and
you know prius plug-in hybrids and stuff
yeah yeah yeah prius prime that's that's
that's electric car right yeah i guess
you could i mean can you go highway
speeds with uh you can and the prius
yeah some people like fill up once every
like half a year if they have local
well yeah but can you get on the highway
even if you're going you're going short
distance alright cool cool
uh
do you mind ethereum on your gpus but
you don't need to deep learn for extra
cash no because power is so expensive
here
um oh what's customer fund oh
uh you'll find out after you raise money
uh
you know it's just
we we want to make sure that that you
know the the comet to
uh
had
it was less reliable than we all would
have liked um you know it wasn't some
people make the situation out to be much
more dire than it actually is but you
know it's not perfect and it's a way
that we can improve
so the customer fund would allow us to
do something like you know if
hypothetically we ever did a a comma to
buy back uh maybe even if your comma two
broke we would include it in the buyback
right now this you know we lose money on
that but it's you know it's like a
customer loyalty kind of thing so that's
that's where the customer fund is you
know
ethereum mining is insanely profitable
yeah maybe it is
it burns our gpus to like oh great we're
making 17 a day burning our gpus
oh
this ford's still out of the question ah
the new f-150 should work
the problem with ford is that it's only
available on the high trim cars
like toyota and honda is available on
all the cars and that's why it's a lot
better you're making
twenty four hundred dollars a month with
10x 30 80s
all right i will briefly do the math on
ethereum mining with our gpus and our
compute
and we'll see if it's worth it
from ctf
is it for the hackathon
is the cdf still going on it's a rolling
submission
oh yeah quality submissions yeah if you
haven't done the ctf yet go do it uh
you're still getting invited to the
hackathon yeah right yeah yeah
yeah yeah the bar is a little higher but
uh yeah if you haven't done the ctf yet
um
i'm better off buying eve instead of
mining yet but that costs money
why not integrate with edge devices
i don't know what that means
integrate
with edge device do you know what that
means i don't know what that means i
don't know what that means sometimes
that you know
again again sunscreen think of all the
cows that stand around in the sun all
day don't they need sunscreen
um in before there actually is cow
sunscreen
uh
and not even proof of stakes
we're very excited at comma for proof of
stake because the gpus are going to be
cheap
what's up alex
seeing how things are going
yeah we talked a little bit about our
fundraising we didn't say anything that
would trigger the sec
we don't like we are we are we are
employers this week oh
oh my god lawyers um
what happened to cherry computer what
you guys like what did i did i raise
money did i incorporate a company no i
wrote a blog post you know some of you
all know the reason i don't stream
anymore
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right
uh
uh
right now 17 of com is owned by
investors
uh
after this round it'll be about 19.
no we were talking about should we be
mining ethereum with our gpus when
they're not training oh i didn't mean to
slow the wear and tear
yeah i don't know but what if it turned
out we could make like a thousand bucks
a day would that be worth it i don't
think so no even a thousand a day a
thousand damage worth i don't think we
can make a thousand today
our data center has like a thirty
percent utilization
oh maybe it's not a bad idea yeah i
don't think it's a thousand dollars a
day though i think it's more like a
hundred dollars a day and now it's like
all right we make 30 grand a month great
it's not really worth it
let's sell one more
i think i think we should just encourage
people to buy more um
torque interceptors
i have serious safety issues right you
know if you see someone you know ever
like like like posting about a torque
interceptor or how they got one to work
like
comma you know again we're about
we're we're 20-person company and we
can't build a torque interceptor
we don't have the we don't have the
ability to do the safety validation
required to like an assad level we
probably could but it requires a lot of
resources
and like it's unfortunately one of these
things that it's very easy to build one
but it's very very hard to build one
that's safe
and the amount of engineering validation
that goes into it right like like comma
has a safety model um and a lot of like
we can mess with our models we can
change we can change our ai models to be
whatever and they don't impact our
safety model because we're using a lot
of the safety that's built into the car
right we use the messages that the car
shipped with
and that the car is designed to use to
turn the steering wheel and to hit the
brakes for adas systems right when you
start trying to hack in eight ass
systems to cars that didn't ship with
them
they put
the the the manufacturers and the tier
ones who make these steering racks put a
lot of effort into making sure those
things are safe um so you know i'd be
really worried if i saw
uh if you see things like torque
interceptors or things start to like
spoof parking modes um using these
things in ways that they were really not
designed for
like open pilot doesn't use the car in a
way that was not designed for we just
put smarter
uh ai basically
in the camera to make better steering
decisions than the ones the stock camera
makes but if you start actually changing
what the controls look like
you're in uh you're in an area where you
can have a lot of issues with functional
safety
um could a panda set off airbags
probably not
uh
there might be some ways to do it but
they would look more like exploits than
they would there's no normal can message
that will set off an airbag the sensors
are directly wired to the airbag
controller um airbags are another thing
that are sld
um
i believe it's as ld to not have
unintentional airbag deployment
because you know again on intentional
airbag deployment you're likely to cause
an accident
um the same is true with a bad
electronic power steering
um
in terms of processing power how big of
an improvement will the new compute
cluster be uh 5x we're looking at 5x
all right look at we're looking at 5x
and what's the what's the 2 million
dollar budget
so uh yeah
at 2 million the whole budget includes
the the build out of all the of all the
stuff we've spent about half a million
on the data center so far so yeah we can
get five x with with two million uh
actually maybe even only a million but
that's the conservative budget
uh all right cool i'm getting asked
about baseball teams this time that's
time it's the end of the stream one
person always remembers yeah
yeah yeah
uh i did like houston i like boston too
they're nice cities but if you said the
yankees
all right bye george bye
so again thank you all for the video
submissions and uh definitely check out
the ctf if you haven't i'll put a link
in the video description you can still
do the ctf and uh we comma hack is going
to be i believe november 12th to 14th
right here in san diego so if you're
still interested in that definitely
check it out
and uh yeah congratulations to the
winners of the video contest and we'll
see you all in a different live stream
later bye